welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Ant-Man of the wasp's quantumania
spoilers coming up so consider this your
warning because we have got to talk
about that very uh populated post-credit
scene guys quite the powerful population
of predatory Portland Pals indeed but
most importantly the apparent leader of
this Council of Kings is the immortus
and it's about damn time too but where
could this immortus Kang variant have
come from and more importantly why is
this a mortise blue and in serious need
of a throat lozenge well I think this
character was actually teased during
Jonathan Major's first MCU appearance
within Loki season 1's finale so let's
take a look at all those clever MCU
Clues together shall we vandered babies
we shall but before we do that make sure
to head on over to nerdwide.shop so you
can buy one of these amazing new
quantumania shirts so head on over to
nerd riot.shop today it is the new home
for New rockstars merch and hey this
video is brought to you by Squarespace
more on them later but alright guys so
I'm sure fans of the Asgardian God of
mischiefs TV series on Disney plus felt
a heavy dose of familiarity with the way
that Jonathan Majors tweaked his voice
as the blue-faced immortus in the
quantum media post-credits scene he
talks like this and dresses like the
pope if the pope was also a blueberry
this is a voice that is suspiciously
similar to the first time Jonathan
Majors did this voice in the MCU when he
was using this voice to pretend to be
one of the fake robotic time Keepers in
Loki episode 4.
swimming
I do not think that this is merely a
coincidence but actually a deliberate
Choice by both Jonathan majors and
Marvel mostly to imply a direct
connection between the timekeepers and
this immortus variant of Kang because
although the timekeepers in Loki season
1 were merely a robotic illusion made by
he who remains as variant of Kane to
keep the TVA Workforce faithful I do not
believe that that specific lie was 100
fabricated and I think that this
post-credits scene of a blue Immortals
along with a mysterious detail from the
Loki season 1 finale point to this
because remember when Loki and Sylvie
are walking towards the elevator at the
Citadel at the end of time and there
were those four statues of the
timekeepers there with one of those
statues mysteriously destroyed and
carelessly left on the ground as Rubble
I believe that this destroyed statue is
supposed to depict immortus from the
quantumania post credit scene I believe
that this is Marvel's clever way of
teasing the mortis all the way in this
finale before they revealed him as the
leader of the Council of Kings in
quantumania but I know what you're
probably thinking time out Mt if this is
immortus then wouldn't that sort of
implied of the timekeepers were actually
real at one point and my answer to that
question is yes absolutely yes but
mostly because of immortus's history
with the very real time Keepers in the
Marvel Comics because in the comics
immortus was actually a very special
variant of Kane the Conqueror one that
actually impressed the timekeepers the
original Berry keepers of the time
stream itself a ton like they really
thought this guy was something else
mostly because they saw that he was the
most sane and reasonable out of all the
king variants as amortus was the oldest
and longest lived of them all I mean
hell comic book King's girlfriend ravona
rensslayer actually co-signs this
assessment as she regards immortus as
all that was ever good in K and being so
the timekeepers wanted to teach him
mortis their vast knowledge on how to
manage the flow of time properly like
they do so that immortus can keep tabs
in all those Kang variants that keep
trying to mess up the timekeepers plans
for all of time the Multiverse
essentially making immortus their new
fourth timekeeper now this all being
said I believe a similar thing happened
in the MCU before he who remains moved
Citadel at the end of time with the
timekeepers finding this immortus
variant and enlisting him within their
ranks to help keep the MCU Multiverse
safe from all of those Kang variants
like I honestly do believe that this was
a citadel built originally by the
timekeepers to house all four of them
well three of them at first and then
four when Immortal destroying the crew
however I believe that a mortis could
have made a massive mistake in his in
his attempt to try to keep all of his
King variants in line and that mistake
was the first iteration of the Council
of Kings you know basically the part of
Hugh remains a story when all the king
variants met each other and had that
short-lived period of Peace as they
shared science and technology for a
while there was peace narcissistic so
congratulatory peace and I believe that
it was during this very Kane con that
immortus would have assembled and
matched the Kang variants that would
have become he who remains and the evil
King from quantumania respectively this
is when he met both of those two
variants but unfortunately like he who
remains tells the Loki's that piece does
not last for very long and all of him
mortis's work trying to organize all
these Kings together to keep the
Multiverse in perfect functioning order
without all those pesky incursions goes
to [__] when all these narcissistic butt
heads butt heads kicking off a
multiversal war likely instigated by the
quantumania Kang and all the other kangs
like him that didn't want to sit around
and do science but instead conquer their
variant Brothers respective universes
instead because that's what Kang likes
to do the concrete like to take [__] and
look guys we're gonna get back to the
video in just one second but I gotta
tell you guys about Squarespace not only
are they making it possible for me to do
this video but they could be making it
possible for you to do but honestly
whatever you want to do online that's
because Squarespace makes it easy to
make an awesome website that lets you
engage with your audience and sell
anything that you need your products
content you create and even your time
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
for building your brand and growing your
business online if you're into making
videos Squarespace can help you create
Pro level videos effortlessly the
Squarespace video studio app will help
you make and share engaging videos to
tell your story grow your audience and
drive sales but hey maybe videos aren't
your thing because you're more of a
social media buff no problem you can
display posts from any profile that you
want on your website and automatically
push website content to your favorite
social media channels so your followers
can share it too no matter what you're
doing Squarespace analytic tools will
help you learn where your traffic and
sales are coming from so you can improve
your website and build a marketing
strategy based either on your keywords
or most popular products and content
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain when we think Squarespace once
again for sponsoring this video but this
is when I believe the Kang who would
become he who remains would find that
Beast between realities called Goliath
and weaponize him to neutralize all the
other kings that rebelled against
immortus and the council agenda
eventually leading quantumania Kang to
be exiled to the quantum Realm by the
very Council of Kings I harnessed the
beast's power and begin experimenting on
it I weaponized
Elias
and I ended I ended the multiversal war
however because he who remains was now a
massive threat with his control over a
life I believe that this immortalist
version of Kane that we met in the
quantumania post-credits scene and the
council may have also exiled he who
remains in their own way as well by
immortus giving he who remains
immortus's old position as the mcu's
timekeeper and making him basically a
glorified administrator of the MCU
sacred timeline so long as he who
remains keeps the Council of Kang's
agenda of pruning the sacred timeline
and stopping it from branching into
other timelines and causing multiversal
incursions essentially just trying to
keep the peace and this is when I
believe he who remains could have moved
into that Citadel at the end of time and
gotten rid of the original time keeper
somehow then making the TVA and
establishing himself as the only keeper
of time because like I said immortus was
one of the few kings that actually was
down to work together with people and
not all versions of kings are going to
be down to work with three other time
Keepers and he remains as one of those
and Hugo remains did that while immortus
concerned himself with keeping all Kings
on the Council of Kings in order as they
continue working on their own agenda
together however unfortunately for the
Council of Kings after eons I think this
exiled winner he who remains finally
realized that his reward was actually a
prison of paperwork responsibility and
loneliness and boredom he was very bored
which is why he remains decided to play
with Loki and Sylvie's lives to get them
to kill him because a narcissistic man
like you came the Conqueror will not be
the one to kill himself he's not going
to be able to do it but with he who
remains his death immortus is now kind
of screwed because now the timelines are
beginning to branch and realities are
starting to cross over with each other
as each of those wild branches touch
each other triggering the big
multiversal incursions that precede
Secret Wars and immortus and all the
Council of kings are not happy about
this like they had this whole structure
and he remains sort of mess it all up so
this being said I have a feeling that
Immortals in the post multiversal war
incarnation of the Council of Kings must
clean up he who remains his mess and get
the sacred timeline in order again by by
pruning timelines by force themselves
that's right everybody all these kings
are coming to fix Sylvie and
in Perfect Circle again but not with the
TVA this time they gonna do it
themselves baby they are going to
conquer but in regards of those three
missing timekeepers I believe that this
might be a secret that Loki season 2
ends up exploring as this shot of Loki
trying to break open an ancient
timekeeper wall can be seen in one of
the Loki season 2 promos kind of
implying to me that Loki is trying to
discover a forgotten piece of timekeeper
history but only time will tell but yeah
that is where I believe this immortus
King actually came from I think he was
actually one of the first time Keepers
that originally lived in that Citadel at
the end of time that we saw in the Loki
finale I mean the timekeepers have been
replaced with duplicates in the comics
before so I think that this is very
likely to be the case in the MCU as well
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mess retainment on Twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some weird [__] and
really fun theories especially the
Marvel trigger Theory which is a theory
that I always talk about about all the
Infinity Stones and how they all tied to
science but most importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
the social medias especially on YouTube
just make sure you hit that notification
Bell so you can get notifications every
time you upload a video and of course do
not forget to hit up nerdwide.shop so
you can buy one of these amazing Ant-Man
inspired shirts but again thank you guys
so much for watching this video I love
you guys so much and I'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you